i mean you are genuinely a fan of the
books and the game and everything
apparently on set you know more than
anyone else i wouldn't necessarily say
anyone else but i i am a
yes i'm a big fan yeah so do you correct
people um i don't necessarily
bit with kyle um who i watched a lot of
um youtube videos of and he was
absolutely fantastic um he was really
informative about how to do all this
stuff and then it's just reading the
manual
which a lot of people don't do and they
end up asking questions online and
people always respond with rtfm which is
read the manual
what are your go-to sci-fi or fantasy
recommendations in the world of books
anything by raymond d feist anything by
david gemmell
anything by brands anderson
and obviously robert jordan's wheel of
time
that was like a shoot from the hip four
in the head
your nerd flag with pride what now one
of your hobbies and he's got a lot of
them ladies and gentlemen one of your
hobbies is you pain makes you sound
weird
you do have more hobbies than the
average man i'd say but you you paint is
it war of war world of warcraft uh
warhammer warhammer i'm a fool
playing a demigod informing your what
your preparation for superman
um
well i'm gonna say theseus isn't a
demigod
that's what he says on wikipedia yeah
wikipedia using wikipedia is your source
of information
there's the painting modelling side of
the hobby and then there's the gaming
side bobby okay and when you paint them
what do you do with them then henry then
you um put them together little armies
and you fight against someone else's
army
i could change the world in some way
[Music]
that's a very good question
i don't really know
you nearly lost quite an important job
absolutely yeah i was um i was playing a
game called world of warcraft i missed
the call from zack snyder to tell me i
got superman
but like did you hear the phone ringing
i did and you chose to ignore it
absolutely
[Music]
did you win the video game
sadly no
so i called him back immediately and
said i'm really sorry i was
saving someone's life
i missed your call which is what i do
all the time
and yeah then you gave me the news so
you were forget yeah you were forgiven i
was playstation or xbox pc oh wow yeah
you're a pc gamer yeah
but was that from when you were young or
yes yeah my dad got me into that when i
was um very very young did you kind of
build your own gaming pc um i have not
quite ventured into building my own
myself i've definitely have i have had
custom pcs over the years um that will
be the next
the next project as soon as i find
enough time and the bravery i might put
my own pc together stronger than regular
humans they're trained excessively and
they are used to kill monsters
and
we find geralt and season two
after having denied the responsibility
of having a child surprise which is
oh goodness this is a long explanation
read the books yeah
i was wondering what the geekiest thing
in your house was i mean aside from your
gaming rig geekiest thing would have to
be my warhammer stuff
we're doing games workshop aren't we
yeah yeah yeah it's um that took me a
while to kind of
confess to openly and publicly a
collection of white undercoat spray
paint that just lurks in the back of the
cupboard yeah it's like what's this uh
for graffiti what's that you have to
dehydrate yourself that's the worst part
of it like diet is difficult um and
you're hungry but when you're
dehydrating for three days
you get to the point on the last day
where you can smell water
like nearby so why did you why did you
do that to get super itchy it gets your
uh it makes your skin really thin so it
sits on the muscles um yeah how do you
feel now do you feel that henry isn't
really able to come out himself now my
moustache bullies me
i can barely sleep at night because it
forces me to put a moustache hammock
onto it so it can sleep so i can sleep
he would have known the driver it is the
master of me right for cardio sake what
do you do for cardio
no cardia no i run
that's the save rianza yeah so what is
the real answer you do
i think they get it
i think okay
my oldest brother was one up was uh four
years older than me he was considerably
larger and incredibly strong
simon um
we
he was so strong that we would make fun
of him by saying hulk smash every time
he got angry
were you guys surprised to find out that
he was a gamer
[Laughter]
no i
pretty hard for you to like come to
something like comic-con and just wander
around and i don't wander around man
like yeah
i walk around sort of back alleyways and
stuff and yeah
[Music]
a a big nfl football fan yes
which is unusual because typically when
someone from england will come here they
get annoyed when i say football
referring to
football football right because soccer's
called football over there but we know
what the real football is it's it's here
but you are uh what fan of
the chiefs right i'm a chiefs fan yeah
how did that happen okay so i spent a
lot of time over here obviously and i've
been watching some american football i
started to like the sport and i realized
i had to choose a team and the only way
i could choose a team was with something
that
was never going to change it wasn't
going to be my buddy likes this team or
whatever it may be
so i figured the one thing which won't
ever change in my life is the superman
aspect of it and i figured superman's
from kansas
the chiefs people in kansas support the
chiefs it just all added so you just
kind of said like oh if superman was a
football fan oh he'd definitely be a
chief he'd be a chief savannah 100 and
you're probably right yeah
wow that's weird
[Laughter]